die erste Frage an Sie ergab er wie oft
denken sie mit Blick auf das was da
gerade in Berlin passiert mist ich habe
zu früh aufgehört
das durch gar nicht mehr ist der Gedanke
Mist die haben mich zu früh abgesägt nee
wieder das alle noch das andere sondern
natürlich
jeder politisch interessiert will ein
Mensch schaut in diesen Zeiten besonders
intensiv auf Politikern auch auf die
eigenen und auf die die Sommer die der
Bundesregierung aber das stimmt schon
ich meine
überlegt wie viel zeitgleiche Krisen
dort bewältigt werden müssen dann glaube
ich nicht dass es jemals zuvor eine
Regierung gab die so unter Druck stand
und so viel gleichzeitig zu bewältigen
hat er das ist schon enorm und deswegen
finde ich auch normal dass dabei gelingt
auch Fehler gemacht werden und nicht
alles ist vorhersehbar
dafür finde ich eigentlich dass wir noch
ein ziemlich stabiles Land sind für die
Dramatik eine Veränderung
stabiles Land die Frage ist haben wir
auch eine stabile Regierung ich glauben
Sie ja das klingt aber letzte Woche hier
der wird ja ein bisschen also wenn ich
sage konsterniert ist es schön schreiben
der war richtig angefasst und da war
sich nicht sicher ob diese Ampel bis zum
Schluss hält notwend bisschen was von
koalitionsdynamiken weiß der weiß
natürlich hält das bis zum Ende weil die
Alternative sind ist das ist eine große
Koalition gibt neuwahlen sind in
Deutschland nicht so einfach zu
erzwingen und da werden alle noch mal
gucken ob sie denn wirklich das Risiko
der Opposition eingehen wollte deswegen
halten die auch zusammen und werden auch
noch ein paar Dinge beschließen habe ich
keine Sorge trotzdem ist natürlich die
letzten Monate das Finden sozusagen
ständig über irgendwelche heizungsfragen
debattiert haben das war schon ein
bisschen erstaunlich dass wir uns so
viel Zeit dafür genommen wir sind ja
unter uns ganz ehrlich sie sehen das und
denken das ist doch nicht deren Ernst
was da läuft oder
naja ich habe gedacht ich hoffe dass das
wäre nicht nur so ein wärmepumpenradar
haben für die Welt sondern schon noch
ein bisschen mehr gucken aber gut auf
der anderen Seite ich war mal zuständig
für das Thema Energie
das wollte ich gerade sagen es ist nicht
nicht überbewertet weil natürlich sie in
der Tat die Klimaschutzziele nur
erreichen können wenn sie auch das Thema
Wärme angehen ich bin nicht so ein Fan
immer dieser Wände Begriffe aber einen
großen Teil von CO2-Emissionen haben wir
unter keinem System geregelt dazu gehört
der Verkehr dazu gehört die Wärmeenergie
und deswegen müssen sie daran ob das so
passieren muss wie das jetzt passiert
ist eine andere Frage aber dass man sich
von dem Thema nicht wecken kann ich
glaube das stimmt reden vielleicht im
Detail noch mal drüber
freuen uns ähm ich weiß nicht ob sie es
mitgekriegt haben Lars klingen weil der
Partei Chef der SPD hier und ich war
überrascht also auf die Frage ob diese
Koalition hält kam kein eindeutiges
selbstverständlich was glauben Sie
eigentlich wo denken sie hin sondern
wir gucken mal ich glaube er kam da
gerade aus der Tiefe der Frustration was
in der Koalition auch letzte Woche
wieder salopp gesagt abgegangen ist wenn
dann
also das ganze fing ja an 30 Stunden
Koalitionsausschuss und alle hatten
gejubelt so das hat sich gelohnt und
dann hat man sehr schnell gesehen nichts
da es ging ins Kabinett die FDP hat eine
Protokollerklärung dazu abgegeben dass
sie das so also auf keinen Fall will
dann gab es ein Parteitag der FDP und so
weiter und so fort und am Ende sagt der
Wirtschaftsminister der dieses
heizungsgesetz auf dem Weg bringen will
die FDP begeht Wortbruch wenn sie nicht
mitmacht und die SPD wird dazwischen im
Moment so ein bisschen zerrieben die
sind auch nicht mit einem einverstanden
was da passiert sind aber so immer so
ein bisschen mehr auf der Seite der FDP
warum ich glaube das machen Sie deshalb
weil sie die Prügel die der grünen
Politiker Habeck und seine Partei gerade
dafür beziehen ganz gerne da lassen
wollen und nicht selber abkriegen wollen
ja und
dann lässt der Bundeskanzler das ja so
ein bisschen laufen man könnte sich
jetzt ja auch vorstellen dass er doch
mal sagt so Jungs in dem Fall sind es ja
mit Herrn Lindner und Herrn
Harbeck Männer rauft euch zusammen das
tut der ganzen Koalition nicht gut das
macht er nicht
klar er hat gesagt was immer ihr
beschließen wollt es kommt im Juni ins
kabinettung das war letzten Freitag dass
er das gesagt hat und jetzt hätte man
sich durchaus vorstellen können dass das
so zwei Monate früher passiert bevor er
erst die ganze Drama wir sehen wer davon
profitiert das ist die AFD und das der
SPD-Vorsitzende dann hier sitzt und in
so ein Loch gefallen
ob das so halten wird ich glaube aber
wie Herr Gabriel sie können nicht
auseinander gehen weil wenn man ein
bisschen dem vertraut was Umfragen
gerade sagen haben sie hat diese
Koalition keine Mehrheit mehr jede
einzelne der Parteien hat in Umfragen
stark verloren und die AFD ist recht
weit oben ja aber es geht doch von der
Verfassung kenne ich ist ja nicht so
dass bei uns mal eine Entscheidung jetzt
machen wir Neuwagen
ganz gekriegt 2015 inzwischen gibt es
verfassungsgerichtsurteile sowohl zudem
wie Helmut Kohl ein sozusagen nicht
echtes Misstrauensvotum herbeigeführt
hat und die SPD 25 auch das geht nicht
mehr und das heißt die Alternative wäre
die Bildung einer großen Koalition ich
glaube Herr märz wurde sofort mitmachen
oder die Ausgangslage verbessert bloß
was hat die FDP und was haben die Grünen
davon nichts und deswegen werden
deswegen also deswegen ich glaube sogar
dass das klingen bei klug genug ist bei
Ihnen hier ein bisschen Druck auf die
beiden zu erhöhen indem er sagt nein
ich glaube nicht dass der auch nur eine
Sekunde daran zweifelt dass die
Kollektion
[Musik]
Nummer abgezogen
da hatte Signale an seine beiden
Koalitionspartner gerichtet und deswegen
sind Ernst so richtig ernst doch wir
sind ja was in der Politik immer tief
besorgt über alles Journalisten auch
wenn Sie mit uns reden aber ich finde
das ist gemessen an dem gemessen an dem
was gerade so los ist in der Welt ist
das echt
sagen wir mal ein nebenkriegischer Platz
und was leider stimmt ist ja wie sich
die Politik dort sozusagen zusammenrauft
oder auch nicht hat Folgen für das
Wahlverhalten und wir sehen dass die CDU
davon nicht profitiert die müsste jetzt
ja durch die Decke gehen nachdem SPD und
Grüne Umfragen runtergehen vor allem die
Grünen das tut sie nicht seine AFD
profitieren und das finde ich wäre würde
mir jedenfalls Sorgen machen wäre ich in
der Bundesregierung aber die Leute ist
ja verheerend es geht ja um die Leute da
draußen die sind verunsichert sie wissen
nicht was soll ich jetzt mit meiner
alten Heizung machen durch meine neue
holen was mache ich wenn ich ein neues
Haus kaufe darum geht's ja und die
Umfragewerte sind ja also Politbarometer
im ZDF hat er jetzt gezeigt dass 51% der
Menschen mit der Bundesregierung nicht
mit der Arbeit der Bundesregierung nicht
zufrieden sind das ist ja verheerend man
braucht ja eigentlich gar keine
Opposition mehr weil die Regierung dabei
ist sich selbst zu Fleisch und das heißt
die beste Opposition ist gerade die FDP
und der Kanzler müsste mal an Machtwort
sprechen und sagen wo es langgeht zu
also ich will das wirklich verteidigen
ich bin seit fünf Jahren gleich dieser
Bundesregierung nicht mehr an ich muss
den muss nicht verteidigen was die da an
an Debatten führen aber das hört sich
immer so an der Kanzler muss man macht
Wort sprechen immer die Realität ist
schon so eine Verfassung das ist ja
nicht schlecht wenn man weiß in welchem
Land man lebt da gibt's solche
Machtworte nicht alle alle Nase lang und
aus seiner Sicht übrigens ist auch nicht
klug ständig alle Konflikte auf sich zu
holen warum soll er das machen warum
soll er sagen übrigens ich entscheide
jetzt jedes Detail dann habe ich auch
jedes Mal hinter Ärger das wird er nicht
tun sondern er wird die zwingen sich zu
einigen ich glaube das ist der das
Signal es kommt im Juni ins Kabinett sie
haben Recht aber alles viel früher
machen haben sie aber nicht gemacht und
ich noch mal ich bin im Bundestag in
Kabine und
ich noch mal ich verteile hier nicht den
den Wahnsinn fünf Monate lang die
Deutschen mit heizungskiller Fragen zu
befassen aber es ist ja nicht so dass
diese Fragen immer mal einfach so
entschieden werden kann das eine
komplizierte Koalition aus drei Parteien
die eigentlich miteinander nichts zu tun
haben wollen und was ist Zeitenwende
seitenwende ist wenn Politiker das
Gegenteil von dem machen müssen was er
wollen die SPD muss Waffen kaufen die
Grünen sucht auf der Welt überall nach
fossilen Brennstoffen und die FDP muss
jeden Tag höhere Staatsdefizit
unterschreiben und dafür dass sie das
sozusagen alles eigentlich nicht wollen
machen es ganz gut und was das Heizungs-
nein ich habe nur ich finde nur das
gemessen an der Dramatik oder stehen
Pandemie Inflation Krieg in der Ukraine
Handelskonflikt mit China Konflikt mit
den USA und vieles andere mehr reden wir
gleich finde ich ist das immer noch
etwas wo wir wenn sie mal im Rest
Europas gucken schauen Sie mal nach
Spanien gerade in Frankreich los ist
dann ist das immer in einem Land vor dem
viele Leute sagen man macht ihr da
eigentlich und nicht zufrieden sind und
trotzdem ist es relativ stabil sie haben
einen Punkt vergessen und das ist der
Klimawandel und da kann man natürlich
auch nicht ganz vergessen was in den
Vorgänger Regierungen auch bei früheren
Wirtschaftsministern nicht erledigt
wurde und wenn man denken Sie daran ja
ich glaube von zwei 13 bis 2017 in der
Serie
also es ist ja sehr langweilig geblieben
der zufällig heute hier sitzt ja man
kann im Rückblick das immer einfacher
beschreiben und es ist aus ihrer Sicht
damals vieles nicht möglich gewesen aber
nachdem
nachdem Putin 2014 die Krim annektiert
hat und die Ukraine und andere Länder
gesagt haben es wird ihm nicht reichen
hat Deutschland weiter auf Gas gesetzt
und sie hat auch sie haben und auch die
Bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt wir mussten
das machen die Wirtschaft zog nicht mit
die wollte günstiges Gas haben alle
unsere Angebote zu alternativ
Energien waren sehr viel teurer und wir
hatten quasi niemanden der damit zog vor
allem in der Wirtschaft das muss die
Regierung jetzt aufräumen und deswegen
nein nein nein
welchen Punkt sie in ihrer Aufzählung
vergessen haben und bei dem
heizungsgesetz zu kritisch ist zu sehen
ist eine Sache ist ja richtig wenn sie
keinen Stichtag nennen wenn sie keinen
ganz besonderes Datum denn ab dann wird
das anders dann passiert das was die
Vorgängerregierung gemacht haben Ziele
zu formulieren und sie dann für die
Bewältigung anderer Krisen zu opfern
erstens haben sie mal schlank das Thema
gewechselt sie haben gesagt hätte
Klimawandel vergessen und dann haben wir
über angefangen über Russland und die
Pipeline zu reden ich will das gerne
auch noch mal erklären
es kompliziert das weiß ich und heute
müssen alles besser 2014 Krieg in der
Ukraine und damals haben wir versucht
mit Herrn Putin über die Frage zu
verhandeln wie beendet man den und wie
sichert man die Erdgasversorgung durch
die Ukraine von Anteil von Europa in
einer solchen Situation wo sie sozusagen
von dem anderen was wollen halte ich es
nicht für eine sehr erfolgsversprechende
Verhandlungsstrategie Ihnen das aus
seiner Sicht wichtigste Projekt in Frage
zu stellen zweitens was sie immer so
gerne verschweigen in den Debatten ist
es gab eine große Debatte über den
zeitgleichen Ausstieg aus Kohle und
Kernenergie ich habe nicht zu denen
gehört die das klug gefunden haben aber
viele andere sie unter anderem auch
fanden das super dass ein Land wenn sie
zeitgleich aus den beiden wichtigsten
Energieträgern aussteigen und im
Wachstum sind sich die Frage beantworten
muss wo man eigentlich Energie dafür her
bekommt wenn gleichzeitig jede Leitung
beklagt wird wo meine neue Stromleitung
legen will oder sozusagen Bundesländer
haben die in Erwin Energie nicht
mitmachen wollen die Frage mussten wir
beantworten und die haben wir
beantwortet in der Tat auch durch eine
höhere Anzahl an Erdgas aber auch nicht
sozusagen vom Himmel gefallen sondern
hat unter anderem was mit Klimaschutz zu
tun weil aus der Kohle zum gleichen
Zeitpunkt ausgestiegen werden sollte wie
aus der Kerne gehen weil wie immer im
Leben den verhindert schlauer ich will
auch gar nicht bestreiten dass die
heutige Regierung ein Thema anfassen
muss dass er den vergangenen Jahren
nicht in gleichermaßen angefasst wurde
warum nicht weil sich die
Vorgängerregierung beschäftigt haben
überhaupt mal europäische Ziele im
Klimaschutz durchzusetzen die gab es
nämlich vorher nicht weil sich die
Vorgängerregierung damit beschäftigt
haben wie wir erneuerbare Energien
ausbauen und zwar nicht nur auf dem
Papier sondern auch tatsächlich
Leitungen bauen ich weiß nicht ob sie
sich daran erinnern welches Theater wir
in Deutschland hatten über die Frage ob
man Leitungen fertig Deutschland zieht
damit der Strom von der Nordsee auch in
Bayern ankommt
das ganze Thema europäisiert was keiner
vorher gemacht hat ja das stimmt das ist
nicht alles aber so zu tun als hätte das
alles keine Rolle gespielt
habe nein ich musste sie leider auch
ausreden lassen jetzt wollen sie das bei
minimal wir können das gerne so
weiterführen aber das Thema ist einfach
wir haben damals auf eine Brücke gesetzt
aus Erdgas weil zwei andere
energiesorten wegfallen sollten und zwar
eine davon unter anderem wegen
biberschutz
tun was hat das keine Konsequenz und
außerdem kann man aber auch nicht so tun
als wäre das alternativlos gewesen ich
mag sie ja persönlich wissen Sie ja aber
jetzt muss ich das leider einmal anhören
in ihrer Zeit auch als
Wirtschaftsminister ist die Abhängigkeit
von russischen Gas und hat uns jetzt
leider den Punkt von von 32% über
50%. ich habe gerade versucht zu
erklären warum das der Fall war schon 15
Jahre Wirtschaft sagst du richtig gutes
Wachstum im Land so da kommen
zeitgleich die Planung auszusteigen was
kann Energie und Kohle das ist doch klar
dass damit der erdgasanteil teilt steigt
wenn sie es nicht schaffen
im gleichen Maße nicht nur erneuerbare
Energien zuzubauen Wind und Sonne
sondern auch Leitungen zu legen damit
der Strom auch da was passiert war ist
doch dass im Norden Deutschlands
winterlich ausgebaut wurde und wenn man
keine Leitung hatten haben wir den den
Polen ins Netz gedrückt die mussten ihre
Kraftwerke runterfahren am rote Zahlen
geschrieben das ist die Lage in
Deutschland damals gewesen und das haben
wir Gott sei Dank geändert und das
stimmt in der Zeit haben wir nicht
zeitgleich das Thema Wärme
in gleichermaßen angefasst wie wir das
beim Strom vorher gesehen haben das ist
so das war der Fehler der Politik
passiert wie richtig im Leben
nacheinander Schritt für Schritt die
Vorstellung man fängt an und dann macht
man einen großen Schritt oder ist die
Reform gelaufen die habe ich in meinem
Leben nicht erlebt ich
erlebt das jetzt zum wiederholten Mal
nicht nur bei ihnen sondern auch ganz
grundsätzlich interessant also
kommt man da nie an den Punkt dass man
mal sagt sorry Leute da haben wir nicht
aufgepasst da haben wir einen Fehler
gemacht und das war kein trivialer
banaler Fehler da meine Situation leider
falsch eingeschätzt und ich sage immer
dazu niemand hat das in böse Absicht
gemacht und ich verstehe den
eigentlichen Punkt verstehe ich total
gut Angela Merkel hat doch exakt das
fortgeführt was die die Sicherung des
deutschen Wohlstands angeht was Gerd
Schröder auch schon gemacht hat nämlich
günstige russische Energie und maximaler
Export nach China das hat über viele
Jahrzehnte deutschen Wohlstand gesichert
und dieses Land so reich gemacht wie es
heute nicht mehr ganz so ist aber wie es
bis vor kurzem noch war ich verstehe das
und ich verstehe auch dass man den
Leuten nicht zumuten kann und sagen kann
Freunde pass mal auf uns geht's blendend
und mit Putin kommen wir auch irgendwie
klar aber ab morgen holen wir Gas
woanders her LG ist das Stichwort und
das wird jetzt auch teurer das hätten
sie keinen verkaufen können also erstens
aber wenn Sie in Ihre Sendung
zurückgehen beim letzten Mal haben wir
ausführlich über die Frage gesprochen wo
der Fehler in der Politik und auch
meiner war nämlich in der Beurteilung
Russlands als so eine Art kleinerer
Sowjetunion das war der politische
Fehler sozusagen nicht zu sehen dass das
Land von einem Status Quo Land in einer
revisionistische macht sich verändert
hat das zweite ist dass wir in der in
der Debatte um die Frage wie sichern wir
den wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand damals
auf erdgasgesetze am hat was damit zu
tun
dass 2002 in Europa entschieden wurde
den Energiemarkt auf den gastmarkt zu
liberalisieren das heißt bis dahin war
der Staat in der Verantwortung auch für
Energiesicherheit und dann war die
allgemeine Auffassung das machen in
Zukunft die Märkte Angebot und Nachfrage
und haben Unternehmen das gemacht was
sie dann machen sie haben sich die
preiswertes der Ressource besorgen ich
habe mal versucht an LG Terminal in
Niedersachsen in Wilhelmshaven aber dort
ein Hafen entwickelt haben hinzubringen
das ist mir von der EU untersagt worden
weil wir der Staatsgeld nehmen wollten
als illegale Beihilfe das heißt das war
gar nicht gewollt in Europa dass es eine
solchen Eingriff der Staates gibt zum
Beispiel für LNG sondern es war das
Gegenteil gewollt dass das alles die
sogenannten Märkte machen weil es war
die Liberalisierung der Energiemärkte
auch daran habe ich den Eindruck kann
sich heute keiner mehr erinnern
anderen Punkt eigentlich um einen eher
psychologischen Punkt und deswegen frage
ich auch ganz bewusst noch mal nach der
Situation ich erinnere mich natürlich
gut an dieses Gespräch dass wir beim
letzten Mal hatten ist einige Zeit seit
dem vergangen und was mir wirklich
auffällt ist es fällt allen aus der Zeit
Beteiligten unfassbar schwer bis heute
einmal sozusagen sorry zu sagen oder dem
Land mal klar zu machen was auf das
waren Fehler sondern im Gegenteil sind
alle immer genervt wenn das Thema kommt
und und
Entschuldigung kommt einem nicht über
die Lippen das fällt mir auch bei Frau
Merkel auf auf gar keinen Fall sie sagte
neulich irgendwie ich glaube im Gespräch
mit giovann konferenzo was soll ich mich
denn für einen Fehler entschuldigen für
etwas von dem ich damals dachte dass es
kein Fehler ist das ist die Haltung
wir setzen doch sie setzen doch ich kann
mir doch sozusagen nur für etwas
entschuldigen wo ich damals wissendlich
eine falsche Entscheidung getroffen habe
und sie hat auch recht wenn sie sagt sie
sind doch damals sehr Überzeugung
gewesen dass das eine das wäre der sich
dann das naja oder fahrlässig oder wie
man sie nennen wollen und natürlich hat
sie recht man kann sich eigentlich nur
für das entschuldigung aber damals
sozusagen hätte besser handeln können
mit dem Kenntnisstand von heute das
haben wir aber nicht gehabt und warum er
doch sie hat mir ein Kenntnisstand sie
hatten nicht überall auf die Krim sie
hatten 2018
das ganze Thema sie hatten Syrien dann
wenig später also die Liste ist wirklich
sehr sehr lang und sie unterschlagen
wieder dass wir damals in einer
Situation waren für die Ukraine die
Erdgasversorgung sicherzustellen Putin
hat immer kurz vor dem Winter den Haaren
zu gedreht also haben wir als Deutsche
und Europäer mit Russland verhandelt
über die Frage wie man das beenden kann
wir haben 2015 dann ein Vertrag
verabredet nennt sich reverse Flow das
heißt wir kaufen das Gas und dann geht
es zurück das funktioniert bis heute ich
weiß im Krieg funktioniert doch mit dem
Strom so ne und dass wir das hingekriegt
haben hat natürlich vorausgesetzt dass
der mit uns redet wenn ich dem sage du
wir wollen was von dir und übrigens dass
Du Dich schon mal drauf einstellst Nord
Stream 2 machen wir nicht ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass der unseren
Forderungen entgegenkommt überschaubar
klein was ich nicht schlimm finde ist
hinterher zu sagen wir haben das
politisch falsch eingeordnet also okay
was ich nicht richtig mag ist dass ich
Leute hinsetzen die diese Fragen damals
nicht lösen konnten die dazu kein Ton
gesagt haben sondern uns nur
aufgefordert haben Heft der Ukraine und
wer das gemacht haben und heute ist
besser wissen und sagen er hätte das
alles gar nicht machen dürfen hätte mit
dem nicht reden dürfen nur Sanktionen
machen das Ergebnis wäre gewesen dass im
Winter in der Ukraine der Hahn
zugewiesen wäre übrigens in einigen
osteuropäischen Ländern auch mir geht es
um was anderes noch mal ich habe
vorausgeschickt ich werfe das niemandem
persönlich vor und ich unterstelle
niemand dem Absicht das tut auch
übrigens verdunst nicht da bin ich mir
ganz ganz sicher und es ging um den
Wohlstand dieses Landes mein Thema ist
er wir sehen heute und da kommen wir
jetzt direkt wieder ins Hier und Jetzt
heizungsgesetz und so weiter das
verhetzungspotenzial dieser Themen die
Unversöhnlichkeit mit der man sich da
gegenüber steht dies echt hart geworden
und und und ich denke manchmal es wäre
gut wenn wir uns wieder alle alle
miteinander auch medial die
verhätzbarkeit dieses Themas wenn man
sich anschaut was was zum Beispiel die
Kollegen von Bild mit Robert Habeck der
gerade veranstalten das ist hart also
wenn wir wenn wir sozusagen
gesellschaftlich wir alle wir haben doch
da einen Job zu erledigen müssen wir
nicht sozusagen nicht das spalterische
rausarbeiten sondern im Gegenteil
eigentlich versuchen gerade in dieser
Situation war vernünftig auch
aufeinander zuzugehen und das treibt
doch die AFD gerade nach oben das treibt
doch diese ganzen Leute nach oben die
der Politik der Politik generell
Misstrauen die sagen da oben sind diese
Eliten und die kümmern sich sowieso
nicht das Problem ist doch dass jeder
den sie dazu befragen ihn Antworten wird
wir machen das doch der Sache der
sachorientiertheit wegen verstehen der
Appell macht das mal vernünftig würde ja
bei den Handelnden die Antwort auslösen
wir machen ist doch vernünftig okay was
ich gerade sagen wollte ist weil das
jetzt so aussieht dass er das so als
erste Mal dass wir so hart miteinander
ringen dann müssen sie mal Jürgen
Trittin einladen er war mal der war mal
Bundesumweltminister und müssen den mal
fragen wie mit dem umgegangen wurde als
es losging mit erneuerbaren Energien als
das erste EEG-Gesetz gemacht wurde wie
sozusagen die die Grünen und er auch
persönlich durch die Medien gezogen
wurden das ist nicht das erste Mal dass
wir solche Konflikte haben und
interessanterweise immer
ausgelöst auch beim Thema Energie auch
ganz unabhängig von erster interessant
haben sie eine Erklärung dafür nee das
ist etwas was jeden betrifft
es ist auch natürlich etwas wo
unglaublich viel wirtschaftliche
Interessen hinter stecken es ist geht um
sehr viel Geld ja und und
ein Thema das alle betrifft und
gleichzeitig unheimlich viel
wirtschaftliche Bedeutung bedeutet
löst große Konflikte aus denken Sie
daran wie wir Jahrzehnte mit schwersten
Auseinandersetzung über die Kerne geht
debattiert haben und daran merken Sie
das ist nicht das erste Mal dass die
Gesellschaft an der Frage so auseinander
geht aber wir haben andere Werkzeuge zur
Verfügung wir haben soziale Netzwerke
zur Verfügung unter anderem also das
verhetzungspotenzial hat noch mal
deutlich zugenommen und wenn man wenn
man die beiden da hinten jetzt sieht
Robert Habeck und den Kanzler Mann sie
waren selber Wirtschaftsminister sie
standen selber da richtig auch im Feuer
und sie haben erlebt wie es ist auch als
Außenminister wenn man von der eigenen
Leuten sogar fallen gelassen wird wie
eine heiße Kartoffel haben sie so erlebt
ja aber ich meine jeder der den Politik
geht weiß dass es sowas geben kann
da gibt der Spruch Leute
jetzt Koalition die haben
für die die streiten ist doch weit
größer als die persönliche
Befindlichkeit von Olaf Scholz wenn der
ausgemacht hat für sich okay der
Entgegner bei der nächsten Wahl ist sehr
wahrscheinlich ein gewisser Robert habe
weg
ist es dann in Ordnung den so im Regen
stehen zu lassen wie sie gerade im Regen
stehen lassen würde ich absolut sehr
reagiert ich würde absolut widersprechen
das Scholz in Harbig seinen angeblichen
endgegnerischen
absolut nicht bin ich ganz sicher dass
er was ganz anderes im Blick hat
zweitens okay dann die Frage lässt
stehen ich gehe mal ich gehe mal zurück
in die Koalition die ich erlebt habe
natürlich ist auch in diesem Koalition
ist so gewesen dass es zwischen
Ministerien harte Auseinandersetzung gab
ich habe meinen Raum verlassen als ein
Vertreter der CSU mit einem Vertreter
der CDU sich so gestritten hat dass ich
gedacht habe als sozialamtlich dabei
sein ich komme wieder rein wenn er
fertig seid das ist boomster
Thema innere Sicherheit Flüchtlinge das
Ergebnis ist jedenfalls natürlich so
dass in solchen Situationen auch die
Kanzlerin und der heutige Kanzler
geradezu dafür sorgen muss dass sie
nicht Teil des Konfliktes werden weil
dann keiner mehr da ist der entscheiden
kann sie müssen jemanden haben der am
Ende den Laden wieder zusammenführt man
kann über die Frage streiten wie früh
oder wie später sowas passieren aber es
kann nicht sein dass der das oder noch
nie erlebt dass die Bundeskanzler in
solche Konflikte sozusagen sofort rein
sind und versucht haben sie zu
entscheiden sofort rein nicht aber jetzt
von uns hat das ja die Dimension
angenommen
also ich sag jetzt mal ungeschützt aber
ich sag's weil ich die Information nach
habe und ich bin mir sicher sie haben
sie auch natürlich ist bei der SPD klar
und von Tag eins dieser Koalition an
klar da gibt es jemanden der könnte bei
der nächsten Bundestagswahl gefährlich
werden oder haben sie der andere
Erkenntnisse
wenn man die Entwicklung sieht mit
diesem Krieg vermute ich dass solche
Überlegung in den Hintergrund treten
erstmal aber in der jetzigen Phase würde
ich sagen ist das so außerdem weiß man
überhaupt nicht ob Herr Harbeck
Kanzlerkandidat wird oder ob es Frau
bärbock werden würde wie die sich noch
mal einigen oder jemand ganz anderes
vorstellen in dieser stimmt dass wir
gesagt haben als Herr Habeck so im
aufsteigenden Asthma haben wir auch
schon gesagt das geht auch wieder mit
ihm runter und das ist jetzt ja auch
passiert sehr beklage an der Debatte ist
dass wir die ganze Zeit über die Art
sprechen und nicht über den Inhalt das
verunsichert die Menschen weiter die
Angst haben sie können das nicht
finanzieren es steht sehr viel in dem
Gesetz es steht sehr viel zu lesen was
diese Koalition plant man könnte
beruhigen man könnte sagen es gibt viele
Härtefallregelungen es gibt Ausnahmen es
gibt
Förderprogramme es wird KfW Zuschüsse
geben aber die Inhalte sind vielen gar
nicht so bewusst im Moment geht es darum
zu gucken kriegt man die Planung in den
Kommunen fertig ob die
Fernwärmenetze Wärme Netze planen und
installieren dass der Einzelne das
vielleicht gar nicht machen muss das
würde schon mal viel Druck rausnehmen
dann die die Kompromisse die geschlossen
werden wahrscheinlich jetzt nur bei
Neubauten ab nächstem Jahr aber eben
noch nicht die alten Häuser dass man ein
bisschen den Druck rausnimmt und so
haben wir eine Gemenge Lage wir haben
die Pandemie gerade überstanden wir
haben diesen Krieg in der Ukraine von
dem wir überhaupt nicht wissen ob er und
wie er eskaliert wir haben den Balkan wo
es gerade sehr gefährlich aussieht wir
haben die Bedrohung zwischen China und
den USA was Taiwan betrifft es über
überfordert viele Menschen wenn sie
diese Gesamtlage haben und sich jetzt
Sorgen machen müssen komme ich
eigentlich mit dem wie ich geplant habe
finanziell mit meinem Haus noch klar und
diese
Ängste muss man nehmen und das macht die
Koalition nicht weil sie die ganze Zeit
der eine sagt dies der andere sagt das
und das war Politik gemacht wird und es
ist teilweise das war auch sehr
interessant dass sie das ähnlich
geläutet haben wie ich auch ja letzte
Woche das klingen weil er sagt und der
wollte hier eine Botschaft setzen das
darf er ja auch ist auch völlig in
Ordnung aber das war das war nicht
sozusagen nur die tiefe Sorge
auseinanderbrechen
Hinweis Freunde man spielt man spielt
mit dem Bruch einer Koalition gar nicht
ich finde das muss man dann
Ausräumen von allen Beteiligten und in
der jetzigen Situation ist es die
Signale deuten darauf hin dass es
tatsächlich so kommt dass dieses Gesetz
in den Bundestag eingebracht wird nicht
verabschiedet aber eingebracht dann hat
die FDP so ein bisschen was gewonnen
weil sie ja dann noch mal in Ruhe
darüber beraten will und dann muss die
Koalition natürlich sehen welches
Interesse hat sie das ist in die
Landtagswahlen in Hessen und Bayern in
oktober kommt die so als mit terms
dieser Ampelkoalition gelten und ob sie
das nicht vorher abräumen will
vielleicht auch die FDP die bisher bei
Landtagswahlen von dieser
Bundesregierung es Beteiligung überhaupt
nicht profitiert hat entweder ist sie
aus der Regierung geflogen oder aus dem
Landtag
ich finde das alles unter dem
Gesichtspunkt wie kann man das besser
machen richtig
aber es ist auch nicht so als ob das das
erste Mal gewesen ist ich meine ich
erinnere mich an eine Koalition coces
und FDP wo die sich gegenseitig Wildsäue
genannt haben öffentlich und trotzdem
nicht zu vergessen wolkentrupp und
trotzdem hat die Koalition gehalten und
hat übrigens ein paar Beschlüsse gefasst
mit an den wir heute noch zu kauen haben
also zum Beispiel eine unter anderem
erst einzusteigen die keine Energie sie
12 Jahre zu verlängern und dann
schneller auszusteigen das ist ein
Operation am offenen Herzen gewesen ich
will nur sagen natürlich ist es nicht
optimal das wissen die Beteiligten auch
aber mir geht's immer um die Frage ist
das eigentlich hat das wirklich für das
Land jetzt eine
destabilisierende Bedeutung ich glaube
dass sie das schaffen können dass auch
wieder zu stabilisieren das wird
vielleicht gar nicht
vielleicht ja das ist übrigens auch
vernünftig dass ich darüber Politik
streitet auch in der Koalition das ist
auch richtig so wir haben lange genug
gar nicht über den Haushalt geredet und
das wird in so Enkel noch viel Geld
kosten
muss auch eine Koalition dürfen ich
finde es auch komisch dass wir Streit
als sozusagen etwas so dramatisches
immer dafür dass dann auch ein Thema der
Medien es muss sie müssen auch eine
solche Debatte aushalten und die werden
sie nicht in der verschlossenen Türen
halten können Stopp also medial gebe ich
Ihnen Recht da da gehen wir im Moment
auch irgendwie sehr hart miteinander um
aber ich sag mal der härteste
Oppositionspolitiker die letzten Wochen
hier hatte war ein gewisser Wolfgang
ja es geht jeder jede Partei hat
sozusagen auch Leute die nur zuspitzen
und versuchen den Konflikt
voranzutreiben ich will das alles warum
ich das eigentlich überhaupt verteidige
ich bin seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr
dabei oder sechs Jahre mit dem Laden
nichts zu tun ich sehe das auch eher als
Bürger und bin auch nicht zufrieden
damit das meine ich doch dass sie können
damit nicht so zufrieden damit aber ich
habe die Sorge dass wir sehen sie nicht
zufrieden da gab es was mit mit der
Weise wie Konflikte in der Koalition
geklärt werden das ist Konflikte gibt
finde ich kein Problem und dass sie auch
mal öffentlich sind finde ich auch kein
Problem aber es dauert zu lange und die
Relation die Relation zwischen was ist
da los in der Welt
und mit was befassen wir uns hier heute
lang die stimmt nicht das ist auch meine
Überzeugung ich sage immer nur das aber
bei meiner Erfahrung in diesem Land ist
das manchmal in der Situation wir alle
sozusagen erschüttert sind was da
passiert und Drama des später wird ein
anderes audisdorf getrieben auch durch
Medien auch durch uns selber ich bin
nicht der Überzeugung dass das Land das
nicht hinkriegt und was das Thema
Bundestagswahlen angeht da stimme ich
Ihnen zu das ist eine halbe Ewigkeit bis
das stattfindet und die Ausgangslage
wird übrigens eine ganz andere sein die
Grünen hatten eine exzellente Situation
weil es keinen amtierenden Kanzler gab
der in die Wahl ging beim nächsten Mal
wird das anders sein und deswegen sind
die Ausgangsbedingungen andere es wird
um die Frage gehen ob so interessant das
oder so absurd das vielleicht jetzt
klingt es wird nie Fragen gehen ob diese
Koalition nicht wieder die einzige sein
wird die die Alternative zur großen ist
es wird wieder so sein ich
prognostiziere das mal dass das
Wahlergebnis arithmetisch am Ende zwei
Möglichkeiten bietet
diese Koalition
und eine große Koalition und da bin ich
mal gespannt wie die die heute die
Koalition intern in Frage stellen wie
die dann reagieren ich habe eine
ungefähre Vorstellung die andere dann
argumentieren die AFD so weitergeht dann
ja eine ganz andere Situation na das ist
ja das ist ja die Tatsache dass die AFD
so profitiert und nicht die CDU
eigentlich müsste in der jetzigen
Situation wenn die Regierung so viel
Ärger hat eine die CDU durch die Decke
gehen dass sie das nicht tut und die AFD
davon profitiert das ist erstaunlich und
das muss uns Sorgen machen aber dadurch
dass die AFD so zunimmt gibt es eben
keine anderen Koalitionen als die Ampel
oder die große
und ich bin relativ sicher wie sich die
Ampel Vertreter die heute gegeneinander
in Clinch gehen
nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl wenn
das die Alternative ist sich entscheiden
werden